charlotte uh thank you so much for
joining us at what must be quite a
difficult time for you just explain a
little bit about your story um how long
have you been in afghanistan now and
what were you told when you left to go
there
uh well i've been coming and going here
as a journalist for the last four years
or so i've been in country the last uh
since the first week of january
uh yeah i mean it's it's a very surreal
situation to be in i felt pregnant um
back in august and i was living in qatar
where it's illegal to be pregnant and
i'm married
uh and i was in
i guess a really difficult position
because i couldn't go back to new
zealand because the borders are shut
even for citizens you have to plan
lottery
to be able to get back in so i started
playing this lottery
and in the meantime i went to my
partner's country which is belgium but
new zealand citizens can only be there
so long on tourist visas
and and we really kind of ran out of
places where we could live in uh for any
extended period of time and we both had
work visas for afghanistan
um so we thought we'd come here until
the new zealand borders reopen or we
apply for an emergency exemption to get
back into the country
and we've been denied by the new zealand
government to re-enter
they say we don't meet the threshold for
needing critical medical treatment and
that we haven't proven we can't get
equivalent treatment here in afghanistan
so
uh it's very surreal i mean the fact
that new zealand's borders are close to
its citizens uh no less in kind of dire
situations um when the country is
already have 93 backs um
there's obviously a lot of questions
around that and the ethics around that
and what's it been like in afghanistan
while you've been there where are you
staying
i mean we have a house here my partner's
lived here for quite a few years also a
journalist
um we just kind of keep our head down i
mean we have work visas to be here i did
talk to some taliban contacts
before we came
just to say you know this is the
situation we we can't get back into new
zealand we can't be in qatar
um
will it be a problem if we come um and
and they said we're happy for you
congratulations
which
i mean it was a real gesture of um
of welcoming and and
empathy of you know we appreciate your
difficult situation come here and um
you know we we wish you the best
so so yes we're waiting here i mean the
new zealand government
i haven't heard anything directly from
them since they rejected us a week ago i
did get an email from a generic email
address just this morning saying we
welcome you to apply under a different
category
but the fact that remains is that they
told us to apply under kind of a medical
critical category um and now they're
saying something else which means
basically they're admitting that there
is no pathway
for a pregnant new zealand woman to
return to give birth um and
i i have so many questions about how how
we've got to this point and
and also kind of the the liability
around that is how how can they justify
it what what are the ethics and
reasoning behind it
especially as you know foreign athletes
foreign musicians um
there's uh the cricket world cup is in
new zealand right now with dozens of
foreign athletes
so how do they justify allowing foreign
citizens in for sporting events and
music events and not their own citizens
in
need of help
and you've got uh a home in afghanistan
um you've had kind words from the
taliban do you feel safe there what
would happen if you
couldn't get back to new zealand as it
seems you can't at the moment and things
don't change and you have to give birth
in afghanistan
yeah i mean i've done plenty of stories
over the years on the state of maternity
care here and it is
dire
um in october i went to a maternity
clinic they didn't have power they
didn't have medicine they couldn't do
c-sections
they had crumpled up some paracetamol in
a newspaper and said we've got this to
give to the woman but that'll run out
next month
um and i mean that's not even talking
about premature gear
so
it is incredibly dire for the woman uh
here and and i am really worried about i
mean i'm 25 weeks today um
i'm worried that if my child a little
girl comes early you know there really
won't be many options for treatment for
her um or myself for that matter if if
she's premature so
uh we really don't want to be here after
about 30 weeks and um
another country has come forward of
which neither of us are a citizen for my
partner and i saying we really feel for
you and can we explore visa options to
try and provide some type of stop gap
for you um in a place that does have
medical
treatment that's equivalent to new
zealand's
so yeah so we're kind of going down that
path as a stop gap and hoping in the
meantime that the new zealand government
um appreciates the needs of its its
citizens abroad
your plan you'll hopefully find another
country that will take you in with good
medical
with a good medical situation that's
literally your only option if new
zealand won't take you back
uh yeah
that's that's pretty much it and you
know
i
am in the media i have a lawyer um
you know i have um i guess resources to
speak out about this but this has been
going on for two years uh with new
zealanders forced to play a lottery to
get back in and then apply for emergency
exemptions if they don't win in
dangerous situations there are thousands
of new zealanders there's a million of
us overseas and and thousands of those
people as you can imagine over the last
two years have had
relatives die have been diagnosed with
terminal illnesses have had visas expire
and have had to go through the same
process that i'm going through now
uh to plead with the government please
let me back in
you know my mother is you know an
intensive care um i don't want her to
die and me not be there i i've been
diagnosed with cancer please let me come
home and see my family and having to
justify and lobby your position